à méditer en plein air se connecter avec
la nature c'est l'enseignement du club
de yoga bouddha top 7 jours sur 7
les adeptes viennent seuls ou en famille
et c'est sur l'eau que le yoga est
pratiqué à terrebonne sur la rivière des
mille îles
les participants de suivre les cours de
laurence bourgault mart a fusionné
d'accord avec votre planche pour cette
professeure le yoga sur l'eau c'est
toute une philosophie on a fait à
travailler sur l'alignement de l'esprit
de l'armée du corps dans le soft google
on le pratique pas ce qu'on devient tout
on se fond dans la nature donc la nature
devient nous et nous on devient la
nature le yoga sur loup appuyé cette
année toute une autre dimension avec la
pandémie les gens en avaient besoin
avait besoin de se connecter avec les
autres aussi malgré la distanciation
avait besoin de se connecter à la nature
pour finalement vraiment ramener la paix
en soit le socle yoga ou le yoga sur
l'eau ne date pas d'hier
le stop ça vient en fait de la polynésie
s'était plus la royauté qui se
promenaient d'îles en îles pour se
déplacer sur des grandes planches de
bois puis ensuite ça a été pour eux
repris par un surfeur émérite d'hawaï et
aux alentours de 1940 après plus d'une
heure sur l'eau les participantes comme
sylvie ont atteint une certaine
plénitude
on arrive avec un bagage dès fois de
tout ce qui s'est passé dans notre
journée la matinée la routine avec les
enfants tout seul car je n'aurais pas
réussi ce rapport avec les idées plus
sorel moment présent en ces temps de
pandémie être en symbiose avec la nature
et reposer son corps et son esprit point
ici tout son sens dans les témoignages
des adeptes du yoga le sentiment de
flottement et souvent rapportée cela
n'aura jamais été aussi vrai avec le
soft yoga ici robert frosi radio-canada
terrebonne